get used to bringing back your empties
Iceland supermarket already gives
customers money off vouchers to
encourage recycling and now the
Environment Secretary has said he
strongly supports a national scheme with
all drinks bottles being sold with a
small deposit returned to customers
through reverse vending machines it's a
measure sky Ocean Rescue has campaigned
for we need to work with business to
make deposit return schemes as effective
as possible but I believe an all-in
model will give consumers the greatest
possible incentive to recycle almost 36
million plastic bottles are used in the
UK every day but less than 20 million of
these are recycled the rest 16 million
end up in landfill litter or a burn for
energy but deposit schemes have
dramatically boosted recycling rates in
other countries and polls show they're
supported by the public and on top of
that you get money off your shopping for
every donation you get so it's a win-win
really it's a good idea at all you know
the recycling their plastic box in their
shops and also you know but some
retailers wanted the deposit return
scheme or DRS to apply to only smaller
bottles with larger sizes collected
through household recycling put a DRS on
top of that is going to take some time
to make sure that we get it right and
that's going to take time to put to
build the machines to purchase the
machines to set up the logistics to take
back all of these materials and also put
in place the recycling infrastructure in
this country so that we're not exporting
the materials abroad for other countries
to deal with this still needs to be
signed off by the next prime minister
but Michael Gove has effectively tied
the hands of whoever that is by so
firmly and publicly endorsing a
comprehensive scheme the only way out
now is with the Prime Minister to
appoint a new environment secretary with
extinction rebellion on the streets
again the government is under pressure
to act on environmental issues from
plastic to climate change
mr. Goh vowed to make legal commits
in a world-leading environment bill
later this year but campaigners will
hold him to it Thomas More Sky News